huge news day but first a correction
people have been asking for more
Corrections so I figure I should make a
few more mistakes to have stuff to
correct right yesterday I said that
Donald Trump's trillion dollar 2019
deficit was a record I should have
clarified a record for his
administration not an all-time record
okay
there is a Minnesota congresswoman named
Alan Omar who was born in Somalia and is
now an American citizen and a member of
Congress as well and Donald Trump
mentioned her during his latest magda
rally in Greenville South Carolina North
Carolina rather yesterday and the crowd
of Trumpets immediately started chanting
send her back send her back presumably I
guess to Somalia let's take a look in a
listen
and she talked about the evil Israel
Trump had said a few things about her
right before this that she looks down on
Americans something about she blamed the
u.s. for what's going on in Venezuela I
believe although maybe that was via
tweet and the reaction of the crowd is
send her back to I guess a reference to
Trump's tweet from over the weekend to
her quote original country and notably
or maybe not notably Donald Trump
doesn't react and you should see the
defenses to this from the trumpets
online the main two defenses I've seen
are number one Trump didn't react and
say send her back therefore he has no
guilt whatsoever in this entire thing of
course the silent complicity really does
have salah say a lot and then number two
defense that i heard is this isn't
literal it's not literally sent her back
no republican literally wants to send
her back they're just saying were
republicans and she's a democrat and we
don't like democrats it's just partisan
bickering with a sort of hyperbolic
statement like sent her back now the
normal reaction from a President of the
United States when a crowd starts
chanting
that an American citizen should be sent
back to a different country should be
how John McCain reacted during the 2008
presidential campaign against Barack
Obama when a woman at one of his events
said Obama is an Arab remember this I
gotta ask you a question
I don't not believing I can't trust
Obama III have read about him and he's
not he's not he's a he's an Arab he is
not no no ma'am no ma'am
he's a he's a he's a decent family man
citizen that I just happened to have
disagreements with on fundamental issues
and that's what this campaign is all
about now yes if you're saying well what
about reacting and saying it's not a bad
thing to be an Arab yes John McCain
didn't do that but at least he did sort
of immediately short-circuit this
woman's delusions but that was not
Donald Trump's reaction naturally as you
can tell as you could tell from the
video as you could probably predict if I
said to you a crowd chanted
send her back about Ilan Omar how do you
think Trump reacted I don't think anyone
would say oh I'm sure he told the crowd
no no no she's an American citizen so
this is now actually getting to the
point where it does sound like and it
does look like the environment in some
of the worst authoritarian regimes that
the history of the world has ever known
the anti-democratic police state houses
of horrors that we've seen over the last
couple hundred years on planet earth and
this is simply not what the United
States was supposed to be I'll be really
upfront with you guys so that everybody
understands this clearly you don't have
to like Ilan Omar or agree with her on
every idea to recognize that this is
simply unacceptable
and this may even be a backfire in some
sense for Donald Trump in terms of his
war with the so called squad these four
ethnic minority congresswoman who are
now getting a ton of attention because
there's been a lot of back and forth
about how the squad is polling and
Donald Trump completely misread a poll
there was a poll that only talked to I
believe it was white people with under
two years of college or something like
that and they don't like these four
women and it's like wow big big surprise
but if you step back a little bit these
are not the most popular members of
Congress nationally now all that really
matters for their reelection is
obviously within their districts but
it's not completely clear to me that
Donald Trump isn't actually helping the
favored favorability of at least some of
these four ethnic minority female
Congress women by what he's doing now
that being said a lot of people simply
haven't heard of these women at all and
simply becoming aware of the fact that
there are these four Congress women is
probably good for them and not
particularly good for Donald Trump but
anyway the point here is this is not a
drill okay this has become actual overt
racism and xenophobia as a platform by
the Republican Party and it is as I told
you earlier this week this is becoming
Trump's strategy for winning re-election
okay it's not a bug it's a feature as
I've been saying it's not something that
they have to try to explain away
or distance themselves from their
actually embracing and understand that
the defense is here to the crowd
chanting sent her back were to defend
Donald Trump and say either Trump didn't
say it himself or merely to say this is
just politics it's not literal it's not
racist it's not xenophobic it's just
politics it's saying we don't like Hill
on Omar's politics remember they started
by saying we're only against illegal
immigration that was their line for a
bunch of you know months or whatever a
year
Alana Lamar came here legally but they
say sent her back even people from
so-called s whole countries can come
here legally but they don't want them
either and this was always a ruse that
is the most important takeaway from this
entire thing they claimed all along to
be against only illegal immigration
undocumented immigration the reality is
that it was a proactive plan all along
to push against non-white immigration
even when it's legal period we can't
stand for it we shouldn't stand for it
they see this as a feature and not a bug
so the only path forward is to remove
every single one of these people from
elected office up to and including
Donald Trump I don't know if we're going
to do it I am very very skeptical of the
success chances at removing Donald Trump
I hope I'm wrong but I don't think it's
looking particularly good at this point
in time I am thrilled to tell you that
today's episode is sponsored in part by
Blink accom slash Pakman Blink astiz a
really unique service for your phone
tablet and web browser and it is
incredibly useful for people like me who
love books and learning but are busy
blinka stakes the best and most popular
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks I'm sure that
if you're like me you have a very long
list of books that you've been meaning
to read you only have so many hours in
the day and that's why blink astiz so
amazing they take the most important
information the themes the insights from
each book and they distill it into a 15
minute audio book that you can
listen to in one sitting I've listened
to a ton of books on blankets our
audience can get a seven day free trial
by going to blink accom slash Pakman if
you're watching on YouTube I've put a
link in the description I have listened
to blinka spokes about economics about
political science about history about
science so many interesting things and
after the free trial if you like it you
can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month go to blink is calm slash
Pakman that's be Li NK is t.com /pa ke
ma n